aujourd'hui je vais apporter des
clarifications suite aux deux vidéos
présentes sur la relativité générale
si vous n'avez pas vu ces vidéos je vous
conseille vraiment d'aller le voir sinon
la vidéo que vous êtes en train de
regarder ne va avoir aucun sens alors
dans la vidéo 17 je vous avais ni la
gravité et l'accélération de son que les
faces opposées d'une même pièce
alors que dans la vidéo 18g sous-entendu
que la gravité était la courbure de
l'espace temps
du coup la courbure de l'espace-temps
est la gravité et non non pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout et je suis
désolé si j'ai pas été assez claire et
que vous avez cru comprendre ça comme
c'était le cas pour mathieu da silva
désole matthieu est désolé à tous seuls
qui ont été induits en erreur par mes
explications
en fait d'un point de vue mathématique
accélération et courbure de
l'espace-temps sont deux concepts très
très très différents est la clé pour
comprendre la théorie d'einstein
il me semble c'est justement de faire
clairement la distinction entre ces deux
concepts
d'ailleurs on peut très bien avoir de
l'accélération sans courbure et de la
courbure sans accélération par exemple
relativité restreinte
on peut très bien étudié des mouvements
accélérée c'est ce qu'on a fait dans le
défilé numéro deux et c'est ce que font
en fait les théoriciens des particules
tous les jours puisqu'il étudie toutes
les forces non gravitationnelle qui
s'applique à l'intérieur d'un espace
temps plat puisqu'il travaille dans
l'espace-temps domingos qui inverse
comme vous l'a dit dans l'épisode 18 la
théorie de la relativité générale à
strictement parler n'étudie que les
forces non gravitationnelle est comme la
qualité n'est pas une force un étudiant
fait aucune force du coup sans force il
n'y a aucune accélération donc la
théorie de la relativité générale à
strictement parler c'est une théorie où
il peut y avoir une courbure de l'espace
temps mais il n'y a pas d'accélération
ceci étant dit tout comme on la
considérait des accélérations dans l'est
de la relativité restreinte
il est aussi possible de considérer des
accélérations à travers l'espace temps
et en fait ce que je voulais j'ai
prétendu dans l'épisode 17 c'est qu'on
suivait justement de trajectoire
accéléré à travers l'espace temps
puisque le sol accélère vers le haut une
ou sur le sol on accélère constamment
vers le haut du coup on peut se demander
mais qu'est ce qu'une trajectoire a
accéléré dans un espace temps il ya une
trajectoire accéléré à travers l'espace
temps c'est une trajectoire qui dévie de
la ligne droite qu'elle est censée
suivre donc par exemple sur ce dessin
vous voyez une représentation d'une
trajectoire accéléré de sheldon
l'espace temple à domingos qui vous
voyez quand on points plutôt que de
continuer tout droit selon sa direction
sheldon va toujours constat moins
cherché à tourner vers la droite et ça
cette volonté à dévier de cette
trajectoire ligne droite c'est vraiment
ce qu'est une accélération dans le cadre
de l'espace temps et bien ce que j'ai
prétendu dans l'épisode 17 c'est que
nous à notre échelle dans notre vie
quotidienne ou l'espace temps et en fait
quasiment plat notre échelle on
reviendra sur la courbure de l'espace
temps dans notre vie quotidienne
à la fin de cette vidéo mais en gros on
peut considérer qu'elle est nulle et du
coup on vivra vendre un espace temps qui
est essentiellement en espace temps
dominique au ski à notre échelle
du coup ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est qu'on dévie constamment de nos
trajectoires en ligne droite non pas
parce qu espace temps et courbet notre
espace-temps encore une fois quasiment
plein mais parce que l'on à cette
accélération à travers l'espace temps
alors j'insiste vraiment sur ce point
parce que beaucoup de très bon
vulgarisateur même des moins bons comme
moi de temps en temps ou ont parfois on
dit que au détour d'une phrase la
courbure de l'espace-temps courbe la
trajectoire des lignes droites
sauf que cette phrase elle est
complètement fausse par définition une
droite ses droits c'est sa part des
bills à dire mais il faut le dire il se
rentrer dans la tête ligne droite ses
droits sur swing ligne droite
on va tout droit ce qui courbent la
trajectoire des objets pour les éloigner
de ligne droite c'est l'accélération et
donc des forces qui seraient du coup
forcément non gravitationnelle est en
fait il ya peut-être une raison pour
laquelle certains vulgarisateur y
compris moi temps en temps par abus de
langage on dit que la trajectoire des
objets devient courbe dans l'espace
temps court c'est parce qu'en fait quand
on raisonne canton réseau les équations
d'einstein où les résout à l'aide d'
espèce de cartes de l'espace temps un
petit peu comme une marque à tort à
utiliser une carte pour représenter la
surface de la terre ce qui se passe
c'est que si on dessine des lignes
droites de la terre dans la carte de
mercator on obtient des trajectoires qui
sont allés à ce moment la courbe et de
la même manière quand on représente des
lignes droites de l'espace-temps du vrai
espace temps dans les cartes de l'espace
temps que l'on utilise va on obtient
aussi des trajectoires courbes
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
vraiment garder en tête que s'il est
possible que dans des cartes les lignes
droites apparaissent courbe en réalité
dont le vrai espace temps ces lignes
droites sont droite par définition et là
je vous invite vraiment à voir et à
revoir les épisodes de 9 11 et 12
surtout le 11 pour vraiment sentir le
fait que les lignes droites sous droite
est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je
déteste cette analogie c'est qu'elle
nous éloigne d'une compréhension de ce
que sont des lignes droites dans des
espaces courbe l'or en parlant de cette
toile thibault lescure trouve que
j'insiste trop sur l'absence du temps
dans cette analogie
mais moi je trouve que j'insiste pas
assis là dessus je trouve que vraiment
la courbure du temps c'est vraiment le
concept important mais d'ailleurs games
sur psp stamm dit très bien que la cause
des trajectoires que l'on observe dans
l'univers n'est pas vraiment une
histoire de courbure de l'espace ça joue
quand même pas mais pas trop c'est
surtout une histoire de courbure du
temps et ça si on y réfléchit et qu'on
comprend un petit peu plus tous les
enjeux de l'espace temps ça devient
presque une évidence parce que lorsqu'on
est dans un espace temps on se déplace
constamment dans le temps pas tellement
dans l'espace puisque à tout moment le
temps parce qu'on avance constamment
dans l'espace temps vers le futur donc
on a un mouvement qui est
essentiellement dans le temps on dit
parfois que nos trajectoires à travers
l'espace temps sont du genre tant ce
genre de phrases que vous pourrez lire
dans les cours de relativité restreinte
et donc quand je fais ce genre de dessin
la courbure que je sous entends quand je
fais ces dessins c'est une courbure à
travers le temps et non pas à travers
l'espace puisqu'elle s'applique à des
lignes droites qui avance à travers le
temps et donc la courbure qui fait que
la terre reste proche du soleil c'est
essentiellement une courbure du temps
qui veulent exclure ajoute que ce qui le
gêne dans l'analogie de la toile c'est
le fait qu'elle représente un espace en
deux dimensions alors que le vrai espace
et dans dimension 3 et sa cellule tout à
fait vrai mais cette analogie encore une
fois elle pas si farfelue cette analogie
on peut la pousser un petit peu plus
loin et considérer qu au lieu de
considérer une toile de dimensions de
dans un espace de dimension 3 on va
considérer une espèce de toiles de
dimension 3 dans un espace de dimensions
qui
avec une direction en plus qu'on
appelait la naca tard pour faire
référence à la vidéo de micmacs et selon
à direction ana cata d'espèces de
hauteur dans la direction ana cata de
cette toile
si on considère que cette hauteur là
c'est ce qu'on appelle le potentiel
gravitationnelle si on suppose que tout
objet dans cette toile de dimension 3 à
l'intérieur de l'espace de livres sont 4
va subir une accélération sous la
direction de plus forte pente le long de
la direction ana cata si on considère
tout ça on obtient exactement les lois
de newton
en gros si on prend la nage il de la
toile et qu on lui rajoute une dimension
des espaces n'obtient un espace de
dimensions 4 et un temps de dimensions 1
ici on projette tout ça sur la toile
c'est garder un espace de dimension 3 on
obtient exactement la mécanique
newtonienne donc cette analogie elle n'a
rien de farfelu
mon problème avec cette analogie c'est
qu'elle représente une mécanique
newtonienne et qu'elle n'a rien à voir
avec la courbure de l'espace temps que
décrit la théorie d'einstein
alors oui j'aurais tant que la bien il
est vrai que des très grands physiciens
comme jean pierre luminet ou encore
brian greene ukip thorn utilisent cette
analogie de la toile ceci dit en tout
cas dans le lien que tu partages jean
pierre luminet dit très bien qu'ils
faudrait aussi inclure le temps dans
cette analogie de la toile et que tout
se passe en fait de façon bien peu
subtil que ce que la toile suggère si
j'ai choisi moi de débuter cette
analogie
c'est absolument pas pour paraître plus
intelligent que ces génies pour parler à
ces gens là moi je suis vraiment le
premier des abrutis
si je choisis de déboguer cette analogie
c'est pas pour les critiquer c'est c'est
vraiment d'un point de vue pédagogique
je pense que pour comprendre la théorie
d'einstein vraiment le fond de la pensée
de nan shan en tout cas moi ça m'a été
hyper utile de complètement abandonner
cette analogie est de chercher
obstinément à penser un espace temps et
pas juste un espace courbet en fait ce
qui me dérange le plus moi
personnellement avec l'analogie de la
toile c'est que quand on la voit on a
l'impression qu'on a compris qu'on voit
cette toile on se dit ah bah tiens bien
sûr la lune tourner autour de la terre
du coup et puis la pomme va tomber sur
la terre sauf que ces pots ces fausses
archives pocock ou plutôt c'est
l'explication newtonienne cette année au
lycée newton
mais l'explication afghane yen est bien
plus subtil et plus élégante plus joli
que tout ça que lors de l'épisode 16 je
vous ai raconté l'histoire de newton et
de cette brillante unification des cieux
et de la terre à travers cette idée de
la gravité qui avait cette même
explication du fait que la pomme tombe
par terre et que la lune tourne autour
de la terre vers ce que l'on voit
comment on passe à la théorie de la
relativité d'einstein c'est qu'en fait
la cause de ces deux phénomènes est
différente
la pomme tombe sur la terre à cause de
l'accélération du sol et la lune tourne
autour de la terre à cause de la
courbure de l'espace-temps deux
phénomènes complètement différent alors
on est tenté d'utiliser le mot gravité
parce que c'est newton qui l'avait
introduit pour expliquer ces deux
phénomènes mais à laquelle des deux est
ce qu'on donne aux mots gravité sachant
que ce sont deux phénomènes différents
vous voyez un peu le problème les
vulgarisateurs ont souvent utilisé le
mot gravité du coup pour chacun des deux
et c'est ce que j'ai fait mais
techniquement ce qu'il faudrait vraiment
faire pour parler de la théorie
d'einstein s'est arrêté d'utiliser homo
gravité le mot gravité n'a pas vraiment
donné aucun pendant dans la théorie
d'einstein
d'un côté on à l'accélération des
référentiels et de l'autre on à la
courbure de l'espace temps
et si on veut raisonner de façon
einstein il faut penser qu'à ces deux
termes et oublier à tout prix des termes
comme force gravitationnelle champ
gravitationnel potentielle
gravitationnelle tout ça en théorie
einstein ça n'existe pas tivo lescure
trouve que j'insiste trop sur le fait
que le seul accélère vers le haut mais
moi je trouve aucun droit qui n'insiste
pas assez sur ça parce que je pense que
c'est vraiment la clé de toute la
réflexion d'un riche si einstein a
décidé de s'investir à 200% sur la
fabrication d'une théorie de la gravité
alors qu'il en avait une qui existait
déjà
c'est parce qu'il était persuadé à
travers son principe d'équivalence cette
idée sur lequel le sol accélère vers
l'eau que la théorie de newton était
incomplète
je pense que beaucoup de gens savent
réciter le principe d'équivalence mêmes
ont une certaine compréhension du
principe d'équivalence
mais parfois quand je leur dis que le
sol accélère vers le haut et ne me crois
pas alors que c'est juste l'application
directe de lieux principe d'équivalence
le principe d'équivalence et
écolosol accélère vers le haut et ça
c'est super difficile à concevoir
c'est une fois c'est à la fois et ultra
bidon ultra simple tout on peut le dire
mais réfléchir il vraiment comprendre
tous les tenants et aboutissants voir
que lorsqu'une feuilles tombent par
terre c'est le sol qui se rapproche de
la feuille voir que quand un avion vol
qui arrive à rester au dessus du niveau
du sol c'est parce qu'il accélère vers
le haut grâce à des forces de pression
puis ça s'est super contre intuitif et
je pense que trop peu de gens fous
l'effort de vraiment voir les points
c'est le principe d'équivalence partout
dans leur vie quotidienne et de voir que
tout n'est qu'une conséquence du fait
que le solex air vers le haut moi j'ai
passé des mois
littéralement quasiment tous les jours à
avoir une petite réflexion sur ça où on
manque je sors dans la rue et je vous
invite à faire de même elle me dit on a
aucune force qui nous tire vers le bas
tout ce que l'on voit tous notre vie
quotidienne
tout ce que l'on voit dans notre vie
quotidienne et sans gravité il n'y a pas
de gravité dans votre vie quotidienne
tout ce que l'on voit c'est un monde en
accélération constante vers le haut et
avoir une super de vidéos de pile psp
stamm celle là je la recommande mais à
200 % celle avec gabe sur qui pose la
question est-ce que la gravité est une
illusion et on a l'impression que c'est
un titre plutôt clip on a l'impression
de se dire ah bien sûr la gravité existe
et leurs cris aigüs effet critiqué pour
avoir mis un titre comme ça mais moi je
pense que ce titre n'est justement pas
[ __ ] clic c'est une vraie question
fondamentale que tout le monde devrait
s'être posé s'ils cherchent à vraiment
comprendre la théorie de la relativité
générale et je pense que n'importe qui
qui se pose la question on arrive à un
moment à conclure que cette question est
très très très très pertinente et qu'on
peut vraiment considérer que la gravité
en tout cas la gravité tels que
l'entendait newton n'ai vraiment aucune
illusion donc plus exactement une foire
d'inertie d'entraînement sérieux je suis
en train de penser à toutes les fois où
j'ai pensé en randonnée que c'était dur
de monter les marches
maintenant que c'est parce que le sol
accéléré trop vite vers le haut vous
garantis que ça retourner ma vision de
la réalité ça m'a fait exploser mon
cerveau plusieurs fois et surtout ça m'a
rendu heureux pendant pendant tous les
maux il ya pensé si c'est pas pour rien
que c'est l'idée la plus heureuse
d'einstein l' einstein c'est un mec qui
a eu des idées incroyables tout au long
de sa
vous imaginez bien que l'idée la plus
heureuse d'einstein
ça va être un truc ultra profond ultra
et oui en effet le seul qui accélère
vers le haut c'est une idée ultra
profonde et je vous invite vraiment à la
méditer encore et encore ça devrait
vraiment faire exploser vos cerveaux
plusieurs fois pendant tout un mois et
puis ma soeur ce qui est super beau avec
cette idée c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir fait un master en physique
théorique pour pouvoir la comprendre
tout peut comprendre cette phrase le sol
accélère vers le haut c'est une phrase
avec seulement six mots qui sont
compréhensibles par plein porte ce qui
est c'est l'une des idées les plus un
crabe l'histoire la physx pour cet
exercice tellement le dessus tout pays
réfléchir que tout peut se rend compte
de toute la beauté de la théorie
d'einstein yen juste en méditant cette
phrase est normalement si vous me dites
est vraiment vraiment vraiment cette
phrase vous devrez avoir énormément de
questions imposer le fait que je n'ai
pas encore reçu tant de questions que ça
qui cherche à analyser ce principe
d'équivalence sous tous ses angles me
fait dire que vous n'y avez pas encore
assez réfléchi et je vous invite
vraiment y réfléchir vraiment à chaque
fois que vous sortez de chez vous l'a
tout de suite après avoir vu cette vidéo
prenez un stylo laissez-le tomber et
réfléchie saisie c'est vraiment une idée
de fou le braille et quand même quelques
questions en ramant cool comme celle de
maliki qui se demandent pourquoi est-ce
que le sol accélère vers le haut il
vient pour apprendre à celle création
faut bien se rendre compte que la terre
c'est pas du tout une petite bille où
rien ne se passe la terre c'est un objet
super géant avec des grosses forces
d'oppression qui apparaissent si bien
que le coeur de la terre et ultra denses
et ultra chaud et que plus on s'éloigne
plus cette pression diminue et en fait
du coup la différence de pression on se
rappelle le gradient de pression ne va
pousser tout sur l'aide de la terre vers
l'extérieur pour ça qu'on a parfois des
montées de magma et qu'elle couvre un
volcan ouf ça explose et que ça peut
monter très haut
du coup au niveau du sol les forces de
pression à l'intérieur de la terre sont
super gordes juste à l'extérieur de la
terre on a l'impression d'être monsieur
eric donc beaucoup plus faible qu'à
l'intérieur et ça fait que satan ça a
explosé c'est un peu comme si vous
preniez un gaz et que vous cherchez à le
comprimer et ça ça va créer des forces
de pressions qui vont faire accélérer la
surface du gaz qui dans le cas de la
terre et le sol à après on peut se
demander quelle est la cause de ces
forces de pression en fait c'est des
particules qui
part dans tous les sens et qui cogne du
coup dès le fin le sol
du coup à force de cogner le sol le sol
accélère on peut se demander après
qu'est ce qui fait que les particules en
entre eux se repoussent et là on tombe
sur l'électromagnétisme en particulier
le principe de paoli et donc si le sol
accélère vers le haut c'est uniquement à
cause des forces électromagnétiques
c'est sur ces forces électromagnétiques
qu'on ressent dans notre vie quotidienne
et en fait tout dans notre vie
quotidienne s'explique à l'aide de ces
forces électromagnétiques
ça aussi c'est juste fou que ça devrait
exploser au cerveau mais aussi beaucoup
d'autres très bonnes questions de thomas
trop je vais en sélectionner une seule
pour aujourd'hui comme un trou chez
demande si la terre devient plus grosse
est ce que les distances reste identique
et ça c'est une question qui en fait
c'est très difficile si vous imaginer
utiliser des lasers vous allez devoir
inclure dans vos calculs la dilatation
gravitationnelle du temps du coup est-ce
que vous corrigez vos calculs par
rapport à ça ou est ce que vous prenez
juste le temps de trajet de la lumière
en compte c'est pas évident on peut
faire une autre expérience de pensée
imaginons qu'on cherche à mesurer la
terre avec une très très grande règle
est ce que les particules de la règle
interagissent entre eux si interagissent
pas entre eux la règle va nous suivre
les trajectoires de l'espace-temps devra
être collée à l'espace au fur à mesure
du temps et du coup la règle va être
emporté par la déviation de l'espace du
coup si on utilise la règle pour mesurer
la terre à ce moment là mais on va voir
que la terre a grossi il inverse si on
suppose que les atomes à l'intérieur de
la règle se repousse parfaitement entre
eux qu'ils ne sortent que la distance
entre chaque atome ne bouge pas et du
coup ils du coup il ya des forces
électromagnétiques qui empêche à la
règle de suivre sa trajectoire normale
dans l'espace temps à ce moment là on va
mesurer tout voir la même taille de la
terre mais vous voyez que ces questions
qui a l'air idiote en fait une question
pour un croc blanc profonde est vraiment
difficile
et d'ailleurs je vous invite vraiment
aller voir cette superbe vidéo de
minutes physique ce qu'il pose la
question est ce que si tout dans
l'univers grossi donc c'est pas tout à
fait le cadre d'origine assez puisque
liée au big bang si tout leur univers
grossi est ce que on grossit aussi dans
l'univers et du coup on devra ne pas se
rendre compte que l'univers a grossi la
réponse est non et ça c'est encore une
fois à cause des forces non
gravitationnelle qu'il faut inclure dans
tout ce raisonnement en fait plus
généralement parler de la terre tout
entier c'est vraiment un truc délicat
parce que la terre
un référentiel locale si vous mettez
différents référentiels inertielle un
peu partout par exemple la surface de la
terre
j'allais voir que tous ces référentiels
l'inertie elles finissent par se
rapprocher les uns des autres et en fait
ne sont pas en mouvement rectiligne
uniforme les uns par rapport aux autres
et ça c'est vraiment la difficulté qui
est liée à la courbure de l'espace temps
dans un espace-temps courbes les
référentiels du sont valables que
localement il est très difficile de
prendre une vision globale sur toute la
terre je dirais même que pareille des
espaces uniquement n'a pas forcément
beaucoup de sens physique en général en
relativité générale
si on veut vraiment observer de façon
physique l'espace-temps de la réalité
générale tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est
essayer de voir ce que voit différents
observateurs donc poursuivre des
trajectoires des observateurs à travers
l'espace temps et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que dans l'épisode 11 je vous avais
parlé de mon vol toronto pékin et que
dans l'épisode 12 je vous ai parlé du
trajet d'une balle de golf
c'est parce que pour comprendre ces
espaces courbe en tout cas d'un point de
vue intrinsèques pour voir ce que voient
les gens à l'intérieur de ces espaces
courbes tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est
vraiment suivre des objets qui vont en
ligne droite
les liens entre deux objets qui vont en
parfois ils peuvent s'éloigner parfois
peuvent se rapprocher mais dès qu'il
s'agit d'étudier la relation entre deux
objets qui vont en ligne droite mais qui
sont pas sur la même ligne droite mais à
ce moment là faut parler de courbure
mais on peut pas avoir de vision globale
de ce qui se passe et on peut juste
parler en termes ils se rapprochent ou
s'éloignent ou des termes un peu comme
ça quoi en fait cette courbure de
l'espace temps elle ne va avoir d'effet
que sur des très grandes dimensions de
l'espace et le temps où par exemple sur
l'espace comprend toute la terre donc
sur des milliers de kilomètres mais à
notre échelle la courbure de
l'espace-temps est imperceptible et ça
ça va me permettre d'enfoncer le clou
sur l'erreur récurrence selon laquelle
la courbure de l'espace temps est ce qui
fait tomber la pomme sur terre en fac ce
nom la courbure de l'espace-temps
éloigne la pomme de la terre oui vous
avez bien entendu courbure de
l'espace-temps éloigne la pomme de la
terre alors je pourrais vous montrer les
calculs en chien qui aura ce versement
fait on peut même le montrer avec la
physique newtonienne si on se place en
physique newtonienne la force de gravité
des croire assurer leur carré du coup la
force de gravité qui est sur le sol est
plus forte vers le centre de la terre
que la force de gravité
sur une pomme qui sera au dessus de la
terre et du coup la force de gravité
accélérerait le sol plus rapidement vers
le centre de la terre qu'elle
n'accélérerait la pomme le sol
accélèrerait donc plus vite vers le
centre de la terre que la pomme et du
coup la distance entre la pomme et le
sol aura tendance à augmenter
et du coup même en physique newtonienne
la gravité éloigne la pomme du sol alors
rassurez vous cet éloignement de la
pomme par rapport au sol et
incroyablement lents il est de l'ordre
du millionième de mètre par seconde
carré donc c'est à peu près le
millionième de l'accélération vers le
haut du sol et ça ça devrait vous aider
à comprendre certains vulgarisateur qui
disent que la force de gravité est
incroyablement plus faible que les
autres forces de la nature
ça c'est complètement vrai la force
électromagnétisme est beaucoup plus
forte que la force de gravité est en
fait la force de gravité n'a des effets
qu'à des échelles cosmique l'échelle de
toute la terre ou à l'échelle du système
solaire mais un autre échelle à notre
échelle locale au niveau de la surface
du sol
tout ce que l'on voit dans notre vie
quotidienne se passe sans force de
gravité tout ce qu'on observe n'est due
qu'à des forces électromagnétiques
donc encore une fois tout ce qui se
passe dans notre vie quotidienne se
passe sans gravité il n'y a pas juste
pas de gravité notre vie quotidienne
elle est imperceptible même si on
voulait à mesurer on aurait bien du mal
à mesurer la gravité sur terre tout la
surface de la terre s'explique bon avec
des forces nucléaires à l'intérieur des
atomes donc sa vie pratique on s'en fout
que et en gros tout le reste n'est due
qu'à des forces électromagnétiques qui
entre autres accélère le sol vers le
haut et ça c'est l'idée la plus heureuse
d'einstein et je vous suggère vraiment
de longuement la méditer j'espère que
vous avez aimé cette vidéo si vous
n'avez pas tout compris
si vous n'avez rien compris
parfaitement normal la première fois
qu'on est exposé à ce genre d'idée c'est
tellement éloigné de tout selon son
habitude que c'est normal de pâques une
phrase il faut du temps un pour
s'imprégner de ces concepts vraiment
vraiment des sentiers c'est pour ça que
nous invite vraiment à y réfléchir dans
votre vie quotidienne
surtout ce principe d'équivalence et
cette idée selon laquelle la gravité
n'existe pas que c'est vraiment une
illusion c'est un truc qui n'existe pas
dans notre vie quotidienne
tout ce qu'on ressent ce sont des forces
électromagnétiques notamment celles qui
nous font accélérer vers le haut je vous
invite vraiment aussi avoir voir et à
revoir les vidéos plusieurs fois parce
que c'est on vous imprégnons encore et
encore de ses idées que vous finirez pas
mieux les seizièmes mieux les comprend
allez voir aussi la vidéo de gabe si
vous parler en anglais
vraiment les vidéos de gameplay seront
excellents et en plus si vous regardez à
la fois des vidéos de gabe et les
miennes bah vous allez trouver plein de
connexion si c'est en mélange un peu ses
explications pour vous comprendrez bien
vu la relativité générale
si vous êtes encore plus motivé que vous
avez certaine familiarité avec des
concepts mathématiques comme la dérive
et vecteur vous fait un petit peu plus
que ça aussi je vous invite fortement
essayé de suivre le cours de richard
taille haie ou à lire le cours des rites
bourboulon c'est ce que j'ai lu pour
apprendre relativité générale c'est très
difficile vous promets que lorsque vous
faites des connexions il ya des choses
qui suis mis dans votre tête
c'est le cliff si je fais ces vidéos
c'est pour que vous ressentiez ce qui
vous me laissez pas tomber pour ceux qui
ont peur que je parte dans les trucs
pour de plus en plus compliquée la
prochaine fois on va revenir sur les
trucs beaucoup plus un puisque je vais
vous narrer les pics aventures de albert
einstein jusqu'à sa découverte de
l'équation de la relativité générale
ça va être beau beaucoup plus simple et
ça fait assez cool vous avez aimé cet
épisode est de penser à mettre plein de
commentaires en dessous à liker et à
partager
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes et j'espère
que je
la prochaine fois en cinq ans du bail de
france en énergie et sa cour et du coup
si je veux savoir les effets de la
gravitation il faut que je passe de ce
référentiel naturel référentiel
inertielle au référentiel d'études qui
est ancien laboratoire
donc il faut que je fasse un changement
de référentiel en restant siens en train
de tomber et le référentiel du labo le
truc c'est que le référentiel simple
c'est pas les anciennes galilée avait là
tu sais pas référentiel de laboratoire
c'est ce livre est en train de tourner
pour étudier la physique dans les faits
ancien du labo il faut que j'étudie dans
le chantier en train de tout médecin
puis je fais un changement de
référentiel vers le siècle immobilisme
que la nôtre vous voyez que celui où la
cour finalement le référentiel du labo
c'est un référentiel accéléré par
rapport au référentiel naturel
référentiels et mercier